in the world of digital marketing you
must have heard the term copywriting
but very few people talk about
copywriting it's one of the essential
skills for any digital marketer it has
been estimated that there are 1 lakh 31
200 copywriters in the united states
today
it is projected that the copywriting job
market will grow by 7.6 percent from
2016 to 2026.
freelance market for copywriting is on a
roll companies like upwork and fiber are
filled with copywriters there are many
advantages of freelance copywriting jobs
like being your own boss a flexible
schedule and doing what you love in this
video we will try to understand the art
of copywriting in very simple manner if
you stick to this video till the end i
assure you that you will have a good
understanding of copywriting hey
everyone i am tushar badiwal welcome to
simply learns youtube channel but before
we begin if you enjoy watching tech
related content consider subscribing to
our youtube channel and hitting that
bell icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session we will start off the session
with an overview of what copywriting is
what does a copywriter do then it's
various types next we will understand
the difference between copywriting and
content writing moving forward we will
discuss the best tools for copywriters
can use
and finally we will end the session by
discussing the job scenario and salary
of a copywriter
so let's begin with our first topic what
is copywriting in simple words
copywriting is a type of writing or a
set of words that will convince the
reader to take some kind of action
and that action can be anything like
registering for an event signing up for
something or buying a product
businesses usually hire copywriters to
write landing pages facebook and google
ads copy social media posts etc in order
to convince the readers to take some
action copywriting should be part of any
marketing plan and is one of the most
powerful ways to capture the attention
of your target audience and motivate
them to convert or purchase copywriting
is everywhere when you go online or even
offline remember the google ad that you
see when you search for something in
google that is a copy or if you check
your email box you will find different
promotional mails by different companies
that are a copy
basically those companies are trying to
convince you to take some action it can
be anything for example an e-commerce
company will convince you to purchase
some of their stored products
now let's talk about the copywriting
formula a good copy usually follows aida
formula a stands for attention i for
interest d for desire and a for action
almost every good copywriter uses this
formula to write better copies and it's
important for you in case you decided to
become a copywriter or want to use
copywriting in some of your work so i
hope now we understand what actually
copywriting is now let's try to
understand what does a copywriter
actually do
the copywriter's job is to write words
that convince an audience to take some
action for the benefit of the company in
which the writer works
let's have a look at sample copyrighted
job description that will help you
understand the role and responsibilities
and the skills needed for this role
so firstly let's have a look at
responsibilities writing editing and
publishing engaging content for various
social media network including facebook
twitter instagram linkedin and google my
business optimizing social media post
language tone message based on your
target audience behavior selecting
appealing images and videos to
complement text for designers to design
the post
let's have a look at some more
responsibilities coordinate with
internal teams to create advertising
posts for client respond to questions
and comments on social media pages
promptly and accurately
there can be more responsibilities to a
copywriter depending on what the company
needs so it varies from company to
company now let's see what skills a
company looks for in a copywriter
hands-on experience using various social
media platform to advertise solid
knowledge of seo keyword research and
analytics tools example google analytics
familiarity with online paid advertising
let's have a look of some others
requirement and skills
ability to deliver creative web content
text image and video excellent
communication skills
so now we know what copywriter does
let's explore its various types
seo copywriting it means optimizing the
copy using keywords to make it rank at
the top of the search results for
example if you optimize a company's
product page correctly through seo
copywriting then there is a high chances
that your sales page would rank at the
top of the search result which would
result in more sales next we have social
media copywriting this type of
copywriting is used on social media
platform for example a catchy title is
used to grab the attention of the user
and emoji is used to make the copy
interesting or frame the right message
in order to convince the audience to
take some kind of action
next we have technical copywriting the
motive for writing technical copy is to
explain the latest technologies or the
technical product that the company wants
to sell for example if you have a tech
product you need a copywriter who can
explain the technical aspect use case of
the product and how that product helped
the customer direct response copywriting
it is a type of communication that is
compelling enough to be able to
influence the customers to act
in other words any copy that encourages
the recipient to act immediately and the
response from the reader are miserable
another type of copywriting is public
relation copywriting in public relation
copywriting you write newsworthy things
to catch your audience attention and
gain their trust it helps you quickly
earn an audience with credible sources
and as a result your business can
promote its product and services more
effectively whenever you search on
google you see some ads at the top of
the search results that are also made up
using copywriting following that next we
have ad copywriting this type of
copywriting is used to create effective
ads generally it's used in facebook and
google ads now we reached the second
last type of copywriting in the list
which is email copywriting as you
understood by the name all the copy that
we use in emails are email copywriting
it includes a good subject line nice
preview text an intro sentence for the
body of your email and a strong call to
action
now let's discuss our last type which is
brand copywriting brand recognition and
connecting with customer begin with
communicating what your brand represents
your brand image can be conveyed through
writing it can be in the form of logo a
song or a phrase to create brand copy
you have to think about your customers
first with this we have come to the end
of this copywriting types list before
jumping into the next topic i have a
task for you just pause this video and
in the comment box type your favorite
type of copywriting i hope you are done
with the comment
let's move forward to our next topic
which is difference between copywriting
and content writing
firstly let's discuss the difference
based on the overall goal
copywriting is a type of writing aimed
at selling a brand on the other hand
content writing is all about building a
perception in consumer's mind the next
difference is based on the length of the
content a copywriter typically writes
short form of copy and a content writer
writes long form of copy text written by
copywriter is brief and engaging content
writer often have to write more in-depth
content explaining a process or topic
now what's the difference when it comes
to a role in a company a copywriter is
someone whose primary role is to create
copy and a content writer often does
more than just write it may be a writer
blogger executive or anyone else
lastly let's discuss the difference
based on seo a good copywriter
understand seo but when it comes to a
good content writer they should know
about the advanced seo
now let's explore some of the helpful
tools for a copywriter copy ai it's an
ai tool and the greatest thing about
this tool is it's very simple to use you
can generate instagram caption product
description and even product value
proposition by just providing a few
words it's a paid tool but it has a 7
days free trial the next tool that we
have is grammarly grammarly is a free
online tool that finds mistakes in your
writing and suggests improvements as you
write grammarly will underline any
mistake you have made and offer
suggestions on how to fix them
additionally it has a plagiarism checker
and a punctuation checker however for
additional features you need to go with
grammarly premium
what tune with the help of grammarly you
can fix your writing mistakes but when
it comes to rephrase and rewording your
content without sacrificing flow tone or
meaning word tune came into the picture
hence the combination of grammarly and
word tune is the best for the copywriter
and it's a paid tool but have a free
plan for beginners
the last tool in our bucket is wordsmith
if you rely on data in your day-to-day
decisions wordsmith is a perfect for you
it can be used for everything from
journalism to financial reporting
because it produces natural sounding
content simply create one template and
set up a few variables and wordsmith
will generate multiple alternative
scripts for example you can write
chatbot scripts for responding to
various complex customer requests
now comes the most interesting and the
last topic of a session the average
salary of a copywriter several factors
determine the income a person can expect
including experience the size of your
company your location and your industry
copywriters are the brain behind
advertisements explaining what the
product does and why people should buy
it they are also responsible for shaping
the brand's identity and tone of voice
copywriters are a valuable resources for
businesses as they are responsible for
writing the first impression customers
get of a company a copywriter earns
approximately 3 lakh 64 000 per annum in
india and in the us he she can earn
roughly 53 000
and when it comes to a senior copywriter
the average salary in india is 5 flag 86
000 per annum and in the u.s he she can
roughly earn 78 000
per year
so with this we have come to the end of
the session on copywriting i hope the
session was informative and exciting in
case you have questions about any of the
topics covered in the session or if you
need resources used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
practitioners will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time this is tushar from the
simply learn team signing off thank you
stay safe and keep
learning hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here